in this video we're going to cover what
is arguably the single most important
concept in all of statistics and maybe
well I mean if you go into almost any
scientific field you might even argue
it's the single most important concept
and I've actually told people that it's
you know it's kind of sad that they
don't cover this you know in the core
curriculum everyone should know about
this because it touches on every single
aspect of our lives and that's the
normal distribution or the Gaussian
distribution or the bell curve and just
to kind of give you a a preview of what
it is and you know my preview will
actually make it seem pretty strange but
as we go through this video hopefully
you'll get a little bit more of an
intuition of what if it's all about but
the defecation distribution or the
normal distribution they're just the two
words for the same thing it was actually
Gauss who came up with it did I think he
was he was studying astronomical
phenomenon when he did but it's a
probability density function just like
you know we studied the Poisson
distribution it's just like that and
just to give you the preview it looks
like this that the probability of
getting any X and it's a class of of
probability distribution functions just
like the binomial distribution is and
the Poisson distribution is based on a
bunch of parameters but it's equal to
and this is how you would traditionally
see it written in a lot of textbooks and
if we have time I'd like to rearrange
the algebra just you get a little bit
more intuition of how it all works out
or maybe we could get some insights on
on where it all came from I'm not going
to prove it in this video that's a
little bit beyond our scope although I
do want to do it and there's actually
some really neat mathematics that might
show up in and you know if you if you're
a mathlete there's something called
Sterling's formula which you might want
to do a Wikipedia search on which is
really fascinating it it approximates
factorials with essentially a continuous
function but I won't go into that right
now but the the binomial I'm sorry the
normal distribution is one over this is
that's normally written the standard
deviation times the square root of two
pi times e to the minus 1/2 and well
just I like to write it this way it's
easier to remember times
whatever value we're trying to get - the
mean of our of our distribution divided
by the standard deviation of our
distribution squared and so if you think
about it actually just is good thing to
just notice right now this is how far
I'm from the mean and we're dividing
that by the standard deviation of
whatever our distribution is and this is
a preview of actually a normal
distribution that I've plotted the
purple line right here is the normal
distribution and just you know the whole
exercise here I know I jump around a
little bit is to show you that the
normal distribution is a good
approximation for the binomial
distribution and vice versa if the
binomial distribution if you take enough
trials and your binomial distribution
will touch on that a second but it's the
intuition of this term right here I
think is interesting because we're
saying how far we away from the mean we
were dividing by the standard deviation
we're saying so this whole term right
here is how many standard deviations we
are away from the mean and this is
actually called the standard z-score one
thing I found in in statistics is
there's a lot of words and a lot of
definitions and they all sound very
fancy you know the standard z-score but
the underlying the underlying concept is
pretty pretty straightforward you know
let's say I had a probability
distribution and you know I get some x
value that's out here and it's three and
a half standard deviations away from the
mean then it's standard z-scores three
and a half but anyway let's let's focus
on the purpose of this video so that's
what the the normal distribution
I guess the probability density function
for the normal distribution looks like
but how did it get there I guess even
more importantly I want by the end of
this video you should at least feel
comfortable that this is a good
approximation for the binomial
distribution if the but if you take
enough trials and that's what's
fascinating about the normal
distribution is that if you have the sum
and I'll do a whole other video on the
central limit theorem but if you have
the sum of many many independent trials
you know approaching infinity that the
distribution of those even though the
distribution of each of those trials
might have been non normal but the
distribution of the sum of all of those
trials approaches the normal
distribution and I'll talk more about
that later but that's why it's such a
good
distribution to kind of assume for a lot
of underlying phenomenon if you're kind
of modeling weather patterns or drug
interactions and you know we'll talk
about where it might work well and where
it might not work so well like you know
sometimes people might assume things
like a normal distribution in finance
and we see in the financial crisis
that's that's led to a lot of things
blowing up but anyway let's let's get
back to this and this is a spreadsheet
right here I just made a black
background and you can download it it
let me write it right here at
khanacademy.org khanacademy.org slash
downloads and actually if you just do
that you'll see all of the downloads I
haven't put it there yet I'm going to do
it right after I record the video this
downloads slash normal distribution
normal distribution distribution that's
distribution that XLS if you just go up
to Khan Academy org slash download slash
you'll see all of the things there and
you'll see that this the spreadsheet I
encourage you to play with it and maybe
do other spreadsheets where you
experiment with it so this spreadsheet
what we do is it's it's we're doing a
game where let's say I'm sitting I'm on
a street and I flip a coin I flip a
completely fair coin if I get heads
let's say if I this is heads I take a
step backwards or let's say a step to
the left and if I get a tails I take a
step to the right right so in general I
always have a 15 this is a completely
fair coin I have a 50% chance of taking
a step to the left and I have a 50%
chance of taking a step to the right so
your intuition there is you know if I
told you I took a you know a thousand
flips of the coin or like you know
you're just going to be you're going to
keep going left and right if by chance
you get a bunch of heads you might end
up really kind of moving over to the
left if you get a bunch of tails you
might move over to the right and we
learned already the odds of getting a
bunch of tails or many many many many
more tales than heads is a lot lower
than you know things kind of being into
equal it being equal or you know close
to equal and right here what I've done
this let me know let me turn into the
let me scroll down a little bit oh yes
okay I don't want to lose the whole
thing alright so what I've done right
here is i have this little assumption
here and i encourage you to fill that
out and change it as you like this is a
number of steps I take this is the mean
number of left steps and all I did is I
got the probability and we figured out
the mean of the binomial distribution
the mean of the binomial distribution is
essentially the probability of taking a
left step times the total number of
trials and so that's equal to 5 that's
where that number comes from and then
the variance and I'm not sure if I went
over this I need to prove this to you if
I have and I'll make a whole other video
on what the on the variance of the
binomial distribution but the variance
is essentially equal to the number of
trials ten times the probability of
taking the left step or kind of a
successful trial that's what you I'm
defining left is a successful trial but
could be right as well times the
probability of you know one minus a
successful trial or non successful trial
in this case they're equally probable
and that's where I got the 2.5 from and
that's all in the spreadsheet if you're
actually you know click on the cell and
look at the the actual form that I did
that although sometimes when you see it
in Excel it's a little bit confusing and
this is just a square root of that
number right the standard deviation is
just the square root of the variance so
that's just the square root of 2.5 and
so when if you look here this says okay
what is the probability that I take zero
steps so I take a total of 10 steps just
to understand the spreadsheet so if I
take a total of 10 steps what is the
probability that I take 0 left steps
well and just to make clear if I if I
take 0 left steps that means I must have
taken 10 right steps and I calculate
this probability and this mean I should
have drawn maybe a line here this is the
binomial eight this using the binomial
distribution and how do I do that well
it's I say what is the probability that
I take is well I take a total of 10
steps so let me actually switch colors
just out of just to make things
interesting let's see do they have a
purple here
blue so the buy blue for binomial so
what I have here is how many total steps
I'm going to take so there's total of 10
steps so 10 factorial that's kind of the
number of trials I have of that I'm
choosing 0 to go left so 0 factorial
divided by 10 minus 0 factorial right
this is 10 choose 0 I'm choosing 0 left
steps of the total 10 steps I'm taking
times the probability of 0 left step so
it's the probability of a left step I'm
only taking 0 of them times the
probability of a right step and I'm
taking 10 of those so that's where this
number came from this point 0 0 1 that's
what the binomial distribution tells us
and then this one similarly is 10
factorial over 1 factorial over 10 minus
1 factorial and that's how I get that 1
and once again if you click on the
actual cell you'll see that explained so
this is we've done this multiple times
it's just the binomial calculation and
then right here after this line right
here you can almost ignore it and I did
that so that I can do a bunch of
different scenarios so for example if I
were to go to my spreadsheet if I were
to go to my spreadsheet and if instead
of doing 10 steps I were to wanted I
wanted to do whoops I should use if I
were to do 20 steps then everything
changes and that's why down here there's
you know after you get to kind of a
certain point the whole thing just kind
of repeats and yeah I'll let you think
about why I do that maybe I should have
made a cleaner spreadsheet but it
doesn't affect the the scatterplot chart
that I did and so this plot in blue and
you can't see it because the the purple
is almost right over and actually let me
make it smaller so that you can see so
finally took let Stanley took 6 let's
say only took 6 steps well it's still
hard to see the difference between the
two and then once again I mean the whole
point of this is to see that the the
normal distribution is a good
approximation but they're so close that
they you can't even see the difference
on line see if you only took 4 steps
okay I think you can see here
the blue here is definitely let me get
my screen drawer on so let me draw this
the blue curve is right around there
right so this is the binomial there's
only a few points here right though the
points only go up to here this is if I
take zero steps left one step left two
steps left three steps left four stuff
left and then I plot it and then I say
what's the probability using the
binomial distribution and then this is
my final position right if I take zero
steps to the left then I take four steps
to the right so my final position is at
four so that's this scenario right here
let me switch my color back to yellow
it's easier to see yellow if I take four
steps to the left I take zero steps to
the right and so my final position is
going to be at minus four right it's
going to be here if I take an equal
amount of both so that's this scenario
then I'm neutral I'm just stuck in the
middle right here right I take I take
two steps to the right and then I take
two steps to the left or vice versa I
take two steps to the left and then I
take two steps right and I end up right
there and so hopefully that makes a
little sense of how this only seemed
like my phone is ringing let me know
I'll ignore that because the normal
distribution is so important and
actually my my nine week old son is
watching so this is the first time I
have a live audience but I think you
might pick up something about the normal
distribution but anyway this is so the
blue line right here and I'll trace it
maybe in yellow just so you can see it
is the plot of the binomial distribution
and you know I connected the lines but
you're often you see the binomial
distribution looks something more like
this or you know this is the probability
of getting to minus 4 this is the
probability of going to minus 2 this
right here is the probability of ending
up nowhere and then this is the
probability see whereas actually now the
point is right here this is a
probability of ending up two to the
right and then this is the probability
of ending four to the right right that's
this is the binomial distribution I just
plotted these points right here right
this is 0.375 this
point three seven five that's the height
of that now what I want to show you is
that the normal distribution
approximates the binomial distribution
so this right here I wanted to say what
what does the normal distribution tell
me is the probability of ending up of
ending up with with exactly zero left
steps and then this is a little bit
tricky because the normal distribution
so the the the binomial distribution is
a discrete probability distribution you
can just look at this chart or look here
and you say what is the probability of
ending up to you know having exactly
having exactly let's say one left step
in three right steps which puts me right
here well you just look at this chart
and you say oh that puts me right there
there's I just read that probability
it's actually 0.25 and I say oh I have a
25 percent chance of ending up two steps
to the what would example is that oh you
have two steps to the right there's a 25
percent chance the normal distribution
function is a continuous probability
distribution so it's a continuous curve
you know it looks like that it's the
bell curve and it goes off to infinity
and starts approaching zero on both
sides alright it looks something like
that but this is a continuous
probability distribution you can't just
take a point here and you say what's the
probability that I end up two feet to
the right because if you just say that
there's the actual the probability of
being exactly and you should watch my
video on probability density functions
but the probability of being exactly two
feet to the right exactly I mean I'm
talking to the atom is close to zero so
you actually have to specify a range
around this and what I assume in this is
I assume that within essentially a half
a foot in either direction right if
we're talking about feet so to figure
that out what you do what I did here is
I took the value of the probability
density function there right and I'll
show you how I evaluate that and then I
multiply that by one so it gives me this
area and I use that as an approximation
for this area that the if you really
wanted to be particular about it what
you would do is you would take the
integral of the of this curve between
this point and this point as a better
approximation we'll go that will do that
in the future but right now I just want
to give you the into
that the binomial distribution really
does converge to the normal distribution
so how did I what is this number right
here well I said what is the probability
well let me let me do something like
that what is let's say this one right
here because I don't want to use the
zero so what is the probability that I
take one left step I kind of used left
steps as as a success so what is the
probability of one and that equaled one
over the standard deviation when I only
took four steps the standard deviation
was 1 so 1 over 1 actually let me change
this because I think it might be it
might be let me change it to a higher
number let's see if I make this I don't
know let me go back to the example where
I'm at 10 all right so if this is at 10
let me go back to my drawing tool okay
so this calculation right here let me do
this calculation actually even better
let me do this calculation right here
all right so what's the probability that
I have two left steps and if I have two
left steps I took a total of 10 steps so
I'm going to have 8 right steps and that
puts me 6 to the right so that's you
know this point right here so what's
that probability how do I figure this
out using the probability density
function how do I figure this height
well I say the probability of taking two
left steps that's how I calculate it if
you actually click on the cell you'll
see that is equal to 1 over the standard
deviation 1.58 1 and i just directly
reference the cell there divided times
the square root of 2 pi and i'll go on
you know I always go out and all the
whole notion of e to the I pi is equal
to negative 1 and all of that but this
is another amazing thing that all of a
sudden we have this you know as we take
many many many trials we have this
formula that has e and Pi in it and
square roots but once again these two
numbers just keep showing up and it
tells you something about I don't know
the order of the universe with a capital
o but let's see so times e to the minus
1/2
times X well the X is what we're trying
to calculate you know two successes so
to be to be to have exactly two left so
it's two minus the mean so the mean is 5
to minus 5 divided by the standard
deviation divided by one point five
eight one all of that squared that's
where this calculation came from and so
and if you really and so I told you in
the last one I mean this just tells you
this right here just tells me this value
up here and I assume that the
probability if I were to know this exact
probability it's the area of this and if
I just take one line the area is zero so
to be exactly two feet away using the
proper remember I mean in this case you
will you can only be two feet away
because we're taking very exact steps
but what the normal distribution is it's
a continuous probability density
function so it can tell us what's the
probability of being 2.18 three feet
away which obviously is only it can only
happen if we're kind of taking
infinitely small steps every time but
that's where it's use is it happens kind
of when you start taking an infinite
number of steps but it can approximate
the discrete and the way I approximate
is I say Oh what's the probability of
being within a foot of that and so I
multiply this height which I calculate
here times B one so you know let's say
this has a base of one to calculate this
area which I use as an approximation so
you just multiply that times one and
that's what you get here and I just want
to show you I mean even with just ten
trials the curves for the you know the
normal distribution here is in purple
and the binomial distribution is in blue
so they're almost right on top of each
other I mean they started when it when
the number of steps I took was a little
bit smaller there and as you take many
many many many more steps
they almost converge right on top of
each other I encourage you to play with
this spreadsheet and actually let me
show you that they converge so I made
another there's a convergence worksheet
on the spreadsheet as well if you click
on the bottom tab
run convergence and I did this is the
same thing but I just wanted to show you
what happens at any given point so let's
say that I wanted to let me explain this
part the spreadsheet to you so this is
you know what's probability of moving
left right this is so this is just
saying I'm just fixing a point what's
the probability and you could change
this of my final position being 10 and
then this tell essentially tells you
that if if I take 10 moves then for my
final position to be 10 to the right I
have to take 10 right moves and zero
left moves and it's a typo right there
should be moves not moved if I take 20
moves to end up 10 moves to the right
then I have to make 15 right moves and
five left moves and likewise if I take a
total of 80 moves if I take 80 flips of
my coin to make me go left to right in
order to end up 10 to the right after
take 45 right moves and 35 left moves in
any order and it'll end up with 10 to
the right so what I want to figure out
is as I start taking you know a bunch of
total moves it's like my total moves I'm
in here I max it out it 170 but you
could kind of say is you know if I
started flipping this coin an infinite
number of times I want to figure out
what's the probability that my final
position is ten to the right and what I
want to show you is is that as you take
more and more moves the normal
distribution becomes a better and better
approximation for the binomial
distribution so right here this
calculates the binomial probability just
the way we did it before and you could
look at the cell to figure it out you
know this says 10 you know I want I use
left moves as a success so this is 10
choose let me you know this is 10 choose
0 and we know what that is it's 10
factorial over 0 factorial over 10 minus
0 factorial times 0.5 to the 0 times 0.5
to the 10 that's where that number comes
from if I go to let's say this one right
here this one right here is calculated
actually let me write it out because I
think it's interesting I have a total of
60 total moves so it's 60 factorial over
I have to have 25 left moves so 25
effect or
60 minus 25 factorial times the
probability of a left move and I have 25
of them times the probability of a right
move and I have 35 of those right so
that's where each of those so that's
just where the binomial what the
binomial probability distribution will
tell us and then it figures out the mean
and the variance for each of those
circumstances and you could look at the
formula but the mean is just the
probability of having a left move times
the total number of moves the variance
is probability of left times probability
of right times total number of moves and
then the normal probability once again I
just use the normal probability I just
use the D so I approximate it the same
way so for example in this situation
right here and Excel has a normal
distribution function but actually typed
in the formula because I wanted to kind
of see that you know what was under
under the covers for that function that
Excel actually has so that you actually
say what's the probability of 25 left
moves I don't know let's say you know 45
left move so I say the probability of 45
left moves is equal to 1 over the
standard deviation so in this situation
the standard deviation is the square
root of 25 so it's 5 divided times 2 pi
times e to the minus 1/2 times 45 minus
the mean minus 50 over the standard
deviation which we figure out was 5
squared so that tells me the value of
what the normal distribution tells me
for this situation with this standard
deviation and this mean and then I
multiply that by 1 so you don't see that
informant I don't actually write x 1 to
actually figure out the area under the
curve right because remember it's a
continuous distribution function like
that
this right here just gives me the value
but to figure out the probability of
being within a foot of it I have to
multiply it by 1 or I'm approximating
really I really should take the integral
from there to there but this little
rectangles are pretty good approximation
and this chart I show you that as as the
total number of moves
gets larger and larger the difference
between what the normal probability
distribution tells us and the binomial
probability distribution tells us gets
smaller and smaller in terms of the
probability of you ending up 10 moves to
the right and you can change this number
here let me let me change it just to
show you you know you could change it
you could say also probably being 15
moves to the let me know I use the wrong
tool you could say what's the
probability of being me 15 moves to the
right and actually that one doesn't 15
moves to the right it looks like it kind
of that's not see the 10 and if I go 12
it converges and then if you go to 13 I
think that something's happening with
the floating point error because you get
two large factorials I think something
weird happens out of here but like if
you do if you do three something weird
is happening
five ten yeah you maybe have to just get
even further out so this for ten you can
see clearly that it converges and I'll
try to figure out while I was getting
those weird sawtooth patterns if you get
eleven now everything is maybe it's
maybe while I do a screen capture
something weird is happening but the
whole point of this was to show you that
if you wanted to figure out the
probability of being 10 moves to the
right as you take more and more flips of
your coin the normal distribution
becomes a much better approximation for
the actual binomial distribution and as
you approach infinity
they actually converge to each other
anyway that's all for this video I'll
continue I'll actually do several more
videos on the normal distribution just
because it is such an important concept
see you soon